am
dr jill drones on about how the thrill
is gone
the president's agenda paused by all the
problems his policies caused and the
list of what they didn't see coming is
longer than one of foods joe enjoys
gumming
yeah screw you dr seuss
new sheriff in town
this weekend first lady professor in
pediatric neurosurgeon dr jill biden
i'm trying
i'm trying
she whined that the stalled progress of
her husband's political agenda is due to
unexpected problems at home and overseas
during a private dnc fundraiser my
invite must have gotten lost in the mail
dr jill lamented the president has had
so many hopes and plans for things he
wanted to do but every time he turned
around he had to address the problems of
the moment or movement
see what i did there
i shouldn't have said that he's just had
so many things thrown his way
it's always sad to see a 79 year old not
have his hopes and plans come true
[Music]
[Laughter]
especially when those plans include
don't go poop poop in the bathtub
but we get it
it's not like presidents are supposed to
anticipate things or rise to the
challenges that every leader faces when
they run the free world instead a normal
president should never expect a crisis
he should just cruise along in a bomber
jacket an aviator sunglasses knowing his
vps got everything covered right cam
you know
if only we had some new kamala
linguistic linguine complete with bongos
i do believe that we
[Music]
should have rightly believed but we
certainly believe that certain issues
are just settled
certain issues are just settled clearly
we're not no that's right and that's why
i do believe that we are living
sadly in
real unsettled
times
perfect
meanwhile
only here
saturday during his final day of his
trip to the middle east joe was
stumbling through it as usual
look
you've heard me say before in in the
in the what in the western mountains of
china and uh and for global initiative
the global infrastructure we had a good
we had a good discussion is this
consistent with inconsistent with who we
are no one's ever wondered what i mean
what i say the questions i sometimes say
all that i mean i just answered your
question do i get it i don't regret
anything that i said
i don't think he remembers it
but it makes sense to me then again i'm
more baked than a plate of ziti judge
what say you joe
hey look look listen to my wife all
right she's a doctor she's right
how am i supposed to get anything done
with all these things happening
trying to make gas prices go down but
they're going up
that's opposite man
and uh
get the global warming thing happening
uh but it's too hot
it's too hot
and
what happened j.lo just married
ben affleck
who saw that coming right
i thought he was gay married to matt
damon
jamie
jamie i like the reasoning that he would
be a great president if nothing was
happening they keep saying this remember
biden himself said this remember he was
like i would get stuff done but people
kept throwing stuff on my desk and she's
like yeah there keeps me problems yeah
you're like the president yeah like if
there was nothing we wouldn't need one
if there was
this that was crazy i hadn't seen that
before the speech where he was just like
he was like you've heard me say it
before and then he just made a bunch of
noises
i thought he was going to say that's all
folks
for a minute there
that was crazy
when i heard he was on a four-day trip i
was like how long was that flight of
stairs
that was good
that was good
so i could see it in my head as it was
coming out
tyrus uh i love how there's all this
back going on right crime and war but
he's the victim because it's hurting him
yeah popularity you know i know the few
times he came out of the
seller
he told us that he had
years
and years of experience right and he has
seen everything you could possibly think
of
except yes everything everything you
could possibly think of
yeah somebody sold us a bill of goods
got filled and it's just a big old
bucket of gruel
not gonna say it not gonna say a cat
i think the problem with biden is that
he was always the consummate coaster he
wasn't supposed to work remember
everything was supposed to go back to
normal and once trump leaves
everything's gonna smooth out no the
world doesn't cater to people who
i don't know the end of that sentence
well you got the first part out
okay thank you that's great
i'll give you a c-plus
i know i actually don't think that they
should have been surprised because what
she's saying is okay he had all this
stuff that he wanted to do but the other
stuff keeps happening
yeah i think
it's been pretty well established that
the presidency is a fast-paced work
environment
[Music]
that's what it's about you have to deal
with things as they come up like you're
the pr you're the the president you know
the i you know what they're saying judge
what they're saying is they wish there
were two presidents the one that's just
like the vice president you know what i
mean like walk around shake joe just
wants to still be the vice president and
then they need a real president which
should be a republican who gets done
well but but the thing that bothers me
is
i know
okay
see a judge when i swear i get more
plots yeah yeah
what try that on the five yeah i will
try it on the five but there's no
audience on the five that's the
difference
here's the thing here's the thing with
her she's as dumb as he is okay she gets
out there and she said we never expected
roe versus white and then she thinks
about it and she says no we actually we
had six weeks from the leak to the real
decision she said but we didn't believe
it okay and then she says you know what
did we know about ukraine we never
expected it all these things just
happened they were building up the
forces for like months and months and
asking job for weapons and what they
didn't know was coming in afghanistan
where we had 13
service people who were killed we didn't
know about it the day you walked in joe
you knew about it what are you talking
about the two of them are lying yeah
that's all i mean
he's never been right on anything right
he's never been right on any foreign
policy issue ever but you know why he's
always happy because he's eternally
surprised by the next moment in time
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think he would have been better i
think he would have been better served
he would have ran for like walmart
greeter yes
there was always something new coming in
hi
eventually someone's gonna find the
handshake if you just stand in front of
the doors and go
tell them
tell the corn pop story
they don't have a choice when they're in
line trying to buy there he would stand
right in front of the cart so you would
have to go through him exactly and then
he'd have to be moved back because you
know he gets
and then you could ask him a question in
what aisle if so when someone he could
say
are you asking me for that's not my job
it's not his job that's what i'm saying
two presidents we should do this a real
president that's republican and then the
guy that is good at playing a president
the democrat the democrats charismatic
the bill clinton the barack obama and
then behind the scenes you got the guy
the mechanic he got donald trump doing
all the weird stuff
i like how they went to jamie nodding if
that would help my nonsense
i saw it coming and really sold it yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else